it's a holiday nightmare for families in
the capital region 14s went out for a
skate on the RTO River Wednesday night
and fell through the ice First
Responders say two were able to pull
themselves out and were treated in
hospital but police search teams were
covered the body of a third and are
still searching for the fourth I highly
doubt that any ice at this point is safe
ice that is really Frozen a balmy winter
has taken Canada by storm the
life-saving society says While most
drownings take place during summer
months about a third of them happen
between October and may most of these
are related to ice incidents so people
venturing out on the ice or you know
people on snowmobiles things related to
winter activities around the water and
Ottawa is not an outlier on Thursday
daily highs across the country hovered
near freezing if not above zero and for
outdoor wreck to be considered safe
sustained freezing conditions are
required it is from coast to coast to
coast Canadians have the same question
where is Witter in Quebec rescue teams
have been searching for about a week for
a four-year-old girl in what officials
are now calling a recovery mission in
Alberta three members of the pelma
family died after likely falling through
the ice while using their UTV near lack
St Anne on Christmas Day and a
61-year-old man died after falling into
the bo River West of Calgary police
believe he was taking pictures of the
mountains you could become disoriented
and even falling over maybe one or two
feet from maybe where you fell in like
the hole would be very hard if
disoriented or you hurt yourself or hit
your head to know how to get back out
officials say before stepping onto the
ice people should check it is at least
15 cm thick for one or two people and 25
cm thick for vehicles Kyle Benning
Global News